[Music]
i am fluent in prague i took like four
years of fraggle in high school i'm very
new to the tribal language so i'll go
with it you ready for a quiz then where
do i sign up go ahead sure i don't have
a lot of fraggles to practice with so
who knows how much i remember did you
say games
i'm in what is a murgle i'm going to
assume it's something to do with music
that is the uh slide that you know well
everyone knows that a mergle
is a special kind of satchel and you
carry around your dueser sticks
in a mergle so you can snack on them
later
right i don't know i don't know what a
merkel is oh they're a race of aquatic
fraggles who live among the roots and
limbs of the great tree
yeah there you go
what are dinkleberries um i have no idea
pretty self-explanatory stinkleberries
are considered delicacy they're terrible
for you rot your teeth they're tiny
they're like some freckles will make
preserves out of them i don't get it
stinkleberries are a berry fruit that
typically grow near the trashy they
smell awful but can be used to unfreeze
a fraggle there it is
it's pretty much what i said no i don't
think so yeah i had that completely
wrong
who's ready
what is up lubius
uh
um
is it something to do with light it's
glowing is it like the end of a tail
come on tail do something
yes the boluvius is the fringe on the
end of a fraggle's tail it tends to
flare out when the fraggle is scared and
can even glow when a fraggle feels truly
at peace with himself see light oh yeah
oh that's right oh it's like a party on
your tail are you kidding me of course
[Music]